ce samedi 6 mai ce sera un événement à
planétaire le roi Charles III sera
couronné à Westminster à Londres mais
l'événement sera aussi très suivi dans
les Yvelines à la British School of
Paris l'un des endroits peut-être les
plus britanniques des Yvelines à mes
côtés de professeurs des écoles à
British School of Paris Joe et Caroline
alors est-ce que c'est un événement très
important pour l'école oui bien sûr
parce que ça fait partie de notre
culture et c'est une nouvelle entrée
historique c'est je pense que 44e
monarche du pays donc depuis Milan donc
c'est très important et on va la fêter
bien sûr c'est c'est bien pour la
culture
oui on le voit il y a beaucoup de
drapeaux ici vous avez également des
petits drapeaux au-dessus de votre tête
est-ce que qu'est-ce qui va être
organisé ici à la British call of Paris
dans l'école et tu les enfants et les
parents sont invités et ils avaient déjà
fait un peu plus de prépuration les
parents il va même du du des choses pour
le street Party et les enfants ils ont
appris de chanter god save the king bien
sûr c'est un petit changement et ils
sont très contents il va être déguisé en
bleu blanc rouge il va porter les choses
comme des lunettes il va avoir des draps
il va avoir de la musique qui va avoir
la danse et ils sont très excités pour
ça oui ça c'est un événement très suivi
au sein de l'école et pour les parents
aussi ah oui les parents de l'école sont
invités
ce week-end aussi il y a des parents qui
organisent les fêtes chez eux et même
que il y a pas tous les enfants bien sûr
qui sont Betty mais en fait c'est une
fête qu'on partage ensemble on a bu que
de nationalités ici mais c'est
en Grande-Bretagne on aime bien faire
les choses ensemble
et voilà on et c'est quelque chose qu'on
va fêter ensemble vous organisez cet
événement depuis longtemps on le sait
depuis quelques semaines cette date du 6
mai à 11h20 exactement pour l'arrivée du
roi Charles à Westminster on la connaît
depuis quelques semaines est-ce que vous
préparez cet événement depuis quelques
semaines également ah oui depuis
quelques temps c'est quelque chose que
on a organisé et on parle avec les
enfants de ça il y a voilà c'est toute
une préparation peut-être pas aussi que
en Angleterre pour le vrai corps au
monde mais en Afrique du temps vous êtes
professeur toutes les deux est-ce qu'il
vous en parle les enfants oui de temps
en temps il pose des questions surtout
ceux qui des événements ils veulent
simplement ce que c'est donc on a
expliqué ou que c'est une grande fête en
fait et c'est après les périodes de
deuil de la Reine Elizabeth maintenant
c'est la plancha le roi Charles
excuse-moi
c'est la grande fête alors au niveau de
la tradition il y aura un plat qui fait
beaucoup parler de lui la quiche du
couronnement qu'est-ce que c'est et
est-ce que vous ici vous allez faire
cette fameuse quiche du couronnement oui
en fait on a donné un lien à l'écran
pour le coronation quiche et c'est un
quiche qui a du épinard du fèves et du
estragon et on attend de moi j'ai jamais
goûté ça alors c'est on va attendre pour
voir comment c'est
un gâteau avec du la crème
confiture très régulièrement en
Angleterre donc c'est on va manger ça
aussi
après la reine Victoria en fait alors je
le précise ça sera les petits qui vont
faire la fête ici les grands juste à
côté sont eux en examen par contre ah
oui c'est ça oui ils sont plein examen
et voilà alors pour eux il va avoir
quelques-unes qui sont en train de faire
des examens alors c'est que pour les
petits ici est-ce que l'histoire de la
reine d'Angleterre des rois d'Angleterre
est enseigné ici est-ce qu'on en parle
beaucoup oui en fait on parle de
l'histoire entre nationale parce qu'en
fait on a une grande ligne avec tuletter
avec plein de choses événements dans
l'histoire et bien sûr les reines et roi
de l'Angleterre sont partis de ça mais
aussi de les autres pays aussi
et samedi vous serez où vous toutes les
deux est-ce que vous allez la regarder
en fait moi j'ai pas en Normandie avec
le
bilingue voilà anglais-français et je
suis sûr qu'on va faire quelque on va
regarder oui avec une quiche peut-être
tu dois essayer et vous Caroline vous
allez regarder le également le
couronnement oui je vais regarder et je
sais que j'ai des amis au Paypal qui
vont se mettre en des amis mais qui sont
hollandais en fait donc il y ait
beaucoup de gens qui qui vont regarder
samedi
et qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
justement de ce roi Charles
je pense il a beaucoup d'expérience et
il est à l'écoute des gens d'impression
qui donne et cultivée moi je pense ça va
bien
qui pense plus que à l'environnement et
architecture de l'avenir de les jeunes
de les jeunes en Angleterre et aussi
voilà depuis
je pense qu'il aime bien de l'or Ilana
nature est-ce qu'on peut terminer par un
peut-être god save the king
[Musique]
et le couronnement du roi Charles III ce
sera donc ce samedi 6 mai à 11h20
environ ici on fera la fête demain et on
l'a compris dans toutes les familles
viennoises on fera également la fête
devant sa télé